bad commercials i love bad commercials
so much thought so much time so much
effort into something for nothing
that's hilarious let's check out bad
commercials here we got bad commercial
timing congratulations daniella thank
you your cookies and cream caterpillar
creations were true to form and simply
delicious
you've earned yourself an advantage in
this all-important main heat
and here she is
she's beautiful
what happened to using this this show is
sponsored by blah blah blah so you
understand commercials are coming they
just ditch that now on tv
this reminds me of when uncle ben
commercial played right eye after
playing no
the worst time
the worst time to put a commercial
ever taco night is heartburn you can
plan for but surprise pizza means
heartburn you didn't expect new santa
360 degrees contains the number one
doctor recommended medicine approved
yeah it's so weird seeing american
medical
commercials i don't think we have that
did we i've never seen it
it works in as little as 15 minutes new
zantac 360. attention zantech users the
fda requested manufacturers to pull
zantac and products containing
reninidine off the market if you have
any of these cancers time is critical oh
now for a free consultation if you don't
win you pay nothing all right am i
supposed to use the same tax or not
please i don't understand can i win
something or do i win cancer it's not
really clear what happens what a what a
dystopian
summary right
attention
[Music]
your ear to try to get her out of the
truck
then they beat her and kicked oh my god
marx and spencer why would you do that
how could you marxist spencer i fully
lean in and support the agenda and hope
that i can be an asset to him but i
respect the fact that he always listens
it's how he was in business it's how he
is as president almost 60 million
americans are affected by mental illness
together we can help them with threesome
nice
they've been waiting on that commercial
they've been waiting in that commercial
i wonder if commercials should really
try and use this in mind this seems like
a good way to go viral
managed
ow thank you commercial
oh that's good
hotels.com hotel inside and out
tech watch thousands of hotel.com users
are now at risk for credit card fraud
go
oh
we know your credit card inside and out
oh this is such a funny i've never seen
any of this it's beautiful
oh there's so many oh no
the fact that they put ads during these
is insane
insane
and these kind of ads
and this is oh my god officer i took off
a breakthrough in shopping is here
wow america man the labs close till
monday you'll get your test results then
consider yourself health-inspected
[Applause]
i i try it
there's no way
there's been a lot of talk about our
season beef but here's the truth
our season beef is 88
premium ground beef
what's the other
what's the other eighteen percent
just go to tacoma.com it's right there
but if you want to know what it tastes
like come to taco bell oh god
american commercials are so cringy you
guys have to watch this there's been a
lot of questions about our beef okay
what but for real though what kind of
human are we talking here i'm not just
gonna eat any human i was overweight
1983. gloria
helped me lose 46 pounds
the aids diet plan helped me lose 28
pounds aids helps control your appetite
so you lose weight what's the name of
the pill
uh-huh
yet aids lets you taste chew and enjoy
and the appetite suppressant in age is
not a stimulant oh aids helped me to
lose 18 pounds and it doesn't contain
anything to make me nervous question
great why take diet pills when you can
enjoy aids aids helps you lose weight
without making you jittery it's not
funny watching cnn last week you
examined the deadly flaws of this
aircraft you joined for newsmen in
remembrance of frank reynolds this week
get the facts about aids a cnn special
report so
it was not just a crazy product it was
also like badly timed
i wonder if the aids company made it the
active ingredient was benzocaine
presumably to reduce the sense of taste
to reduce eating later change in the
candy diet pills and all this stuff it
just blows my mind that it's even a
thing man wow
dozens of bumps and bruises why he says
he's actually goddamn lucky let's go
free
[Laughter]
[Music]
i can't wait to go
why is it so funny it's funny because i
don't know i don't need to explain it mr
clean magic eraser extra power was three
times faster on permanent marker it
looks like mr clean has won everything
the cleaning games are finished
your child has cancer mr clean did what
mr clean did what to my child damn they
really have no chill
[Music]
what is really in these impossible
burgers cut off sausage man's hand
[Music]
whoa
that was dope
[Laughter]
let's go
drives hands while using 80 less energy
than conventional hand dryers oh wow
more than one in ten children and adults
have noise induced hearing loss
permanent hearing damage done by
everyday sounds in the environment and
this teen is damaged the alarm about one
possible cause hand dryers those goddamn
hair dryers but they do use eight
percent less energy
i think i'll buy
i never use those i do one of them
and then
and then i walk around a little bit like
that five seconds five to ten seconds
i'm good
[ __ ] hair dryers that's a scam just give
me the goddamn paper [ __ ] the
environments oh no
[Applause]
whoa this is a pizza cutter
when you order domino's carryout get
three topping pizzas for seven years
a pizza car i want some pizza right now
what yeah why was he cutting why
okay i think i think i watch every
single bad timing ad thing that was
really fun i enjoyed that i kind of want
to check out infomercials next but if
you enjoyed this as well subscribe for
more epic content hit the bell
march
just give me your money
why is it so difficult i have new merch
represent.com super happy about this so
i think you guys will like it check it
out